welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of obi-wan
kenobi episode 2. let's break down all
the details you missed from how riva
knew vader was anakin why the grand
inquisitor isn't dead and did mark
hamill show up in this episode we opened
on daiyu as obi-wan starliner arrives
through the thick green murk of the
planet daiu is a new planet to star wars
and the arrivals and departure board as
all the signs are in this episode are in
the language of auravesh in this case
most of the words reading starliner with
various different numbers and
destinations further back behind obi-wan
as he walks off the liner written in
blue it's a sign that reads machinery
and radar maintenance i think i'm gonna
try this to translate all these the deck
officer tells obi-wan you're in die you
know all signals in or out are blocked
people like their secrets out here now
the show's designers say they based
daiyu on the city of hong kong maybe a
little commentary here about how uh
these days connectivity is a bit jammed
in that part of the world the wide
street shot shows more aurabesh market
gungan snacks bank and milk we know from
venomous that gungans like jar jar love
to snack then he comes across this
familiar face
yes this is tamer morrison as a clone
trooper but this is not rex this guy's
blue armor makes him a member of the 500
and rex broke off with ahsoka to form
the 332nd who painted their helmets
orange to honor her now there are not
many clone troopers left ever since
tarkin decommissioned them as we saw
during bad batch this clone sure may
have been part of that massacre of the
jedi temple and now just feels broken
and depressed racked with guilt or maybe
he's a clone trooper who defected from
that mission and was ostracized either
way give this guy a mini series i want
to know his story obi-wan eyes him
apprehensively seeing both part of the
group who slaughtered his fellow jedi
and the face of commander cody his clone
trooper companion who shot at him he
meets this young female spice dealer oh
someone's daughter wants to yeah this is
a fun little wink because she is played
by esther rose mcgregor ewing mcgregor's
real life daughter her character's name
is tether grigg a derevant of her name
and she offers him some spice i got a
castle pure glitter stem and fellution
kessel pure means it comes directly from
the spice mines of kessel a location we
visited in solo and the endpoint of the
kessel run glitter stem is a form of
spice often mentioned in star wars lore
produced from the webs of spice spiders
and fellucian means it comes from
felucia the planet with interesting
plant life where ayla sakura was gunned
down in order 66. camille nanjiani plays
haja estri a con artist who pretends to
be a jedi notice how he wears a huge
fake lightsaber out in front of his
robes yes it's super obvious and that's
the point because jedi are always
supposed to hide their lightsabers
beneath their robes if he was a real
jedi it wouldn't be out in the open like
that he gets some safe passage to the
planet corellia which is the home planet
of han solo that we saw the beginning of
solo after the woman thanks him well
does this hilarious impatient cough it
up gestures with his hand
it's all there oh you didn't have to
every credit and then notice how he
counts at coin four coin despite
pretending not to care obi-wan exposes
him but in my experience rats know more
about the sewers than anyone else yeah i
like how in this episode we're back to
seeing blade runner obi-wan from attack
of the clones a guy who was not afraid
to explore the underworld to locate its
target they passed some more signs some
translate to sw milk made for star wars
milk and then a red sign for sabach that
of course is a star wars card game
actually later this episode you see the
same sign the bottom having a whole hand
of sabot cards and then even later in
the episode we see hasha playing a
solitaire variant of the game and then
in this alley in purple there's a sign
for a club called the den and another
sign in green wine ben twists his beard
hair as he scopes out this alley it's
actually the same gesture alec guinness
did in a new hope and mew and mcgregor
mirrored this in the final scene of
revenge of the sith his way of showing
that he's starting to age up and
transform into that era of the character
now this hooded man walks past obi-wan
on the left side of screen and yeah he
looks a lot like mark hamill hamill has
cameoed in these live-action disney plus
star wars shows before he did voice the
bartender droid in the mandalorian now
if this is him we shouldn't overthink it
luke is not time traveling here star
wars has uh looser logic rules for
cameos remember e.t showed up in revenge
of the sith ben enters this spice
processing lab looking like a meth lab i
like how smoothly he pickpockets the
spice from the guard as he brushes past
him ben then tussles with more guards in
the quarter including the zabrak and if
you watch this very closely even though
ben is super out of shape and that's
really fun to watch as he takes all
these hits it's not that his hand is
just weak when he punches them if you
look closely he cuts his hand on one of
the zabrak's horns something i always
wish we would have seen with maul's
horns now last episode showed a hooded
leia revealed to actually be a decoy and
this episode keeps up that game but in
this case it's a trap for ben but ben is
prepared for this you're bleeding all
over my floor well
everybody believes
yeah i love this line because obi-wan
has always been around for the most
visceral violence in star wars his
scuffle with panda baba slicing maul in
half shooting grievous's heart out and
of course high grounding anakin and then
later riva finds her kidnappers as high
as obi-wan's ground is and i think this
is the first time in star wars we've
seen characters truly high on spice and
i love this when obi-wan finds leia he
leans forward toward her in the same
exact pose that matches leia's pose when
asking obi-wan to help via r2's hollow
recorder even the same kind of blue
lighting covering them both i just love
that we finally get to see these two
characters together a major character
pairing that we've never gotten before
as the two of them never really shared a
moment together in a new hope he says
your father sent me
i'm here to help you where's the army
yeah the moment kaidomir is luke
rescuing her in a new hope
short for stormtrooper
i'm luke skywalker i'm here to rescue
you riva meets up with the other
inquisitors now joined by the fourth
sister a character whose armor actually
shows up in the return to the vader's
castle comics worn as disguised by rebel
commander lena graff riva says i found a
link between him and organa in the
archives i use the girl as bait that
link in the jedi archives that the
inquisitors now have access to might
have been bail organa visiting the jedi
temple on the night of order 66 before
poor young zetjukasa died protecting him
or it might have also been obi-wan's and
bale's christosus venture in clone wars
the grand inquisitor says whatever power
you are
craving it will not change what you are
and what is that the least of us
you came to us from the gutter yes some
context of why riva has such a chip on
her shoulder and why they call her riva
more often than third sister if i'm
right that that youngling we saw in the
prologue was riva maybe after escaping
the temple she spent some time on the
run that fear leading to anger leading
to hate leading to suffering and then
out of that bitterness toward obi-wan
and out of desperation she volunteered
to hunt him down as an inquisitor riva
defies the grand inquisitor though by
transmitting obi-wan's bounty to every
bounty hunter his mug shot reads wanted
obi-wan kenobi offense's high treason
reward upon capture and i like how they
used a revenge of the sith publicity
photo of ewan mcgregor one bounty hunter
eats a giant rib with all the signs for
gunkin snacks around this actually might
be a kadu rib khadu being the writing
mounts of the gungans of naboo remember
kadu rib was listed on the menu at the
diner in the mandalorian season 2 finale
and you can actually get a kadu pork rib
at disney's galaxy's edge the red neon
sign behind him reads swords maybe a
reference to luca's film producer john
swartz now i'm not a skin care
aficionado but i prefer my face to not
look like i've been lost in the dunes of
tatooine i want to take care of the
money maker well the fine folks at
geology have hooked me up with some
skincare products that i have loved
geology is a nine-time award-winning
men's skincare company that creates
simple effective personalized skin care
products for men so click the link in
the video's description and take a 30
second quiz tell them about your skin
and their team dermatologist designs a
regimen just for you that shifts
directly to your door it's great for
folks worried about acne dark eye
circles wrinkles signs of aging they
send you a 30-day trial set that's easy
to incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skin care or seasoned
expert here's what they sent me everyday
face wash repairing night cream vital
morning face cream and some nourishing
eye cream so far today just using this
everyday base watch has just made my
face feel more comfortable on my head
like i don't have that awkward like
that tightness that sets in in the
middle of the day it just feels like my
skin is like a nice blanket on my body i
don't know if that makes sense to you
but i'm just like aware of my skin now
and it feels nice really by designing
these things i love that they do the
thinking for me they send me just what i
need and i just have to use it and they
are offering a crazy deal right now you
can get 70 off on their 30-day
five-piece trial kit so head to
geology.com to get 70 off on your 30-day
trial kit when you use the promo code or
just click on the link below that's
geology.com promo code rockstars70 to
save 70 off on your 30-day trial as ben
looks around the corner another sign
reads chumo threads there was a shumu
wong chinese film actor in the 40s and
50s but i'm not sure if there's a
connection there leia throws some shade
at old man ben if anyone asks were
farmers from tall and you're my daughter
granddaughter maybe
what nothing
i mean really in the next nine years
both of them are about to hit some
massive age changes now one of the
bounty hunters is an lon series droid
like four loom who joined bosque and
boba fett and the empire strikes back
but according to edward chow this guy is
actually named one jack leia asks i read
that jedi can make things float make me
float
what i want to float if you think about
it in the last jedi leia will finally
pull off an oppressive force-powered
space float another pink neon sign
translates to jawa's market and then on
the rooftop riva looks past a sign that
reads milk meanwhile leia gets spooked
by obi-wan's face on the bounty alert
another example of riva's chaotic evil
tactics making obi-wan's life hell this
chase heads to the rooftops where the
bounty hunters fire on ben as reeva
parkhouse her way over to them leia
tries to jump away but falls short
losing a grip on the wire and i love the
inverse coloring of this moment leia and
green falling into the red ben's face
lit red bat with a green smog backdrop
and ben finally uses the force on this
series to catch her a move that calcus
actually does in jedi fall in order to
save prof revealing himself as a jedi
for the first time and by the way that
sequel game jedi survivor is set five
years after fallen order which roughly
sets it around the same time when this
series takes place maybe making it a bit
more possible that cal kestes could show
up on the show the orbish signing this
alley by the way translates to noodle
obviously a noodle bar but also
reflecting how obi-wan finally uses the
powers of his noodle and later in this
alley reba scans hajja's noodle but haja
saves them from that elohim droid and
points into the cargo report where an
orbis sign reads mock inc is a machine
incorporated he says that shuttle will
take them to the planet mapuzo
confirming the translation of the
inquisitor table that i did from a
trailer mapuzo being a deep cut location
from the role-playing game the fact that
trailer footage shows that on the
inquisitor's screen means that they're
going to chase them there which is bad
news for the people who want to help
obi-wan there and we'll see maybe it's
some other runaway jedi maybe calcus
maybe ahsoka there's quite a few of them
still alive out there the grand
inquisitor turns his spinning lightsaber
on fleas kidnapper character whom we
learn is named vect no crew this
spinning effect is one of the more
lethal aspects of the inquisitor's
sabers and yes they can use this to fly
leia boss has been around now come on
what
nothing you just remind me of someone
[Music]
she was fearless too and stubborn was
your friend a jedi too
no she was a leader i love it so obi-wan
compares leia to her mother padme a
queen turned senator of naboo a leader
but he may also be thinking of his lost
love sateen but really what i love most
about this line is he answers whether or
not she was a jedi with no she was a
leader which means jedi in his mind
should not be leaders which makes sense
after the clone wars after order 66
obi-wan probably feels quite a bit of
regret that the jedi got so involved in
that military conflict and that they
never should have been generals in the
republic military moses ingram is legit
creepy as reba
i love how the increasing red glow of
her saber precedes her entrance in the
frame this whole moment feeling very
similar to vader playing hide and seek
with luke and returns the jedi she says
she wants to take him to vader revealing
lord vader will be pleased
you didn't know
he's alive obi-wan anakin skywalker is
alive
so a few things here first i just love
how reba can sense obi-wan sudden
confusion upon hearing that anna can
survive but second how does riva know
that vader and anakin are the same
person this is supposed to be a secret
known only to a few people like
palpatine vader obi-wan yoda for riva to
know means she must have some deeper
insight into anakin than most others do
perhaps as a young lane she could have
idolized anakin skywalker and she was
able to put it together that this new
sith on the scene was giving her the
same kind of feels that anakin did i
think ultimately this just gives us an
insight to how smart riva is because
after all thrawn was able to deduce that
anakin and vader were the same person
based off of a specific flight maneuver
that vader did that thrawn knew that
only anakin skywalker could do riva uses
her lightsaber to stab the grand
inquisitor in the gut but again the
grand inquisitor is guaranteed to
survive considering he shows up years
after this in rebels he might get that
same kind of mod shop treatment that
thundercat gave fenik chand maybe
they'll rush him to a back to tank
either way if vader can survive
immolation granny can survive this so
obi-wan stunned to know anakin is still
alive
spirals you okay
anakin
what a smash cut we see the face of
hayden christensen his eyes now sith red
in the back to tank his breathing the
same sound effect of vader's iconic
breathing through his mask so right off
the bat the first shot we see of darth
vader on the show is not the iconic mask
it is the face of hayden christensen
making a promise to the viewers that
darth vader on the show isn't just gonna
be james earl jones voice coming through
the mask we're gonna be spending a lot
of time with this guy underneath the
mask now while the bacta tank is
supposed to be a regenerative healing
tank that he must reside in while not in
his suit this water doesn't look
restorative in this moment visually it
looks like he is in boiling water
steaming with rage and as we saw in the
book of bobo that laying in these back
to tanks has a sensory deprivation
meditative quality it causes you to
reflect on your unresolved issues and
that is what vader's going through right
now and a cool little visual detail here
though it is hard to see the gnarly scar
is on his bald head the same one on his
head when luke unmasks him at the end of
return of the jedi so in this moment we
do not yet know if vader was just waking
from a nightmare charles amazing 2017
comics show how he experiences them a
lot they are terrifying and obi-wan
factors heavily in them but the editing
at least implies that it was obi-wan
speaking his name for the first time in
10 years that could have awakened this
monster because this is after all the
first time ben has spoken the name
anakin on this series other characters
have said it like owen and bale but not
ben for these first two episodes bennett
successfully resisted using the force
and letting his conscious mind drift
back into the jedi thinking but now that
jedi itch that the grand inquistor
warned of the itch they cannot help has
gotten the best of obi-wan and he made
the mistake of finally opening his mind
to his former padawan as a living threat
and even the simplest most forgivable
thought crime has put a bullseye on him
that's all the stuff i love coming out
of episode two episode three is coming
wednesday of next week so when that
drops tommy and i will once again be
doing our wikileaks after show covering
all the big questions coming out of it
with my breakdown coming out the next
day on that thursday and the best way to
support new rockstars is to check out
our merch over at newrockstarsmerch.com
including a new obi-wan kenobi inspired
shirt design looks amazing and when you
get one of these you'll get the added
option to ride in a custom shout out
that will appear at the bottom of our
obi-wan kenobi after shows wookie leaks
so get on this best way to support us
new rockstarsmerch.com so be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars follow me on
instagram and twitter ida boss follow me
rockstars thank you so much for sticking
with us and we'll see you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you